This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Ting: mobile that makes sense.
THE SEA STARS ARE DYING OFF AND TURNING INTO
GOO.
WHAT KIND OF NIGHTMARE PLANET ARE WE ON?!
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
One of my first experiences that I can remember
with the ocean involved a huge wall of sea
stars.
Guys -- it was magical.
So it's slightly traumatizing to hear that
some kind of plague is sweeping the sea star
population.
Last November, scientists up in the Vancouver
and Seattle region started noticing something
really strange: hundreds of sea stars had
their limbs detached and their bodies turned
to goo.
At this point in their investigation, the
scientists think it's a pathogen that debilitates
their immune systems.
The limbs dissolve off and fall away while
the infection just disintegrates the rest
of the poor animal.
Since November, the disease has spread down
the coast as far south as Mexico, and they've
even seen it in Maine and New Jersey.
In some populations, up to 95% of the sea
stars have died off.
So, we've seen illnesses like this before,
and it's all turned out okay - but this time
is particularly alarming because of the SHEER
NUMBER of animals that are dying.
Plus, it's been almost a year and...well...they
still don't know WHAT exactly the disease
is or HOW it's happening!
The fact that it's on 2 separate coasts with
no connection to each other is strange - how
the heck is this thing spreading?
It's also concerning because sea stars are
top predators in their ecosystem.
They're the keystone, the backbone, the star
of the tide pool show!
Without them (or without an adequate population
of them) the balance of the tide pools could
change in a few key ways.
For one, sea stars feed on mussels, so without
any threat, we could see a massive mussel
takeover!
Which, to be honest, my stomach probably wouldn't
mind.
I might be able to handle those excess mussels
singlehandedly.
But on a more serious note: slugs.
Sea stars also eat sea slugs, or more specifically,
slug larvae.
So without any population control, those could
also take over.
These critters all play a role in maintaining
the chain of command in the ecosystem -- they
regulate the availability of nutrients for
other animals and aerate the sediment.
It's probably not the end of the world as
we know it, but hey: it's significant.
The fact that multiple species of animals
are dying off without explanation is a big
deal -- especially given what we know about
humans' contribution to polluting our oceans.
In recent years, we're responsible for all
kinds of toxins that wreck unknowable havoc
on marine life -- but hey, we can't be sure
yet that there's a connection there.
Thanks for joining me for DNews everyone,
we'll be back soon with more science updates.